welcome to sauce talks money we're all
we talk is money I'm your host Adam
sosnick and I'm here to help you build
wealth and to save that money today
we're gonna be breaking down the cares
Act which is the 2.2 trillion dollar
economic stimulus plan are you ready
let's talk money now before we take a
deep dive into the cares Act as you can
see behind me a lot of different colors
down a different numbers a lot of
different moving parts let's just cover
one thing this is really complex stuff
now what's our goal our goal is to
simplify money and break down money into
a language you can understand so by the
end of this video you're gonna take all
these complicated stuff and say you know
what I kind of get it now thanks all
right let's jump into it now what I have
right here is what I would call not so
fun facts facts that aren't exactly easy
on the ears not so fun fact number one
here we go our current national debt is
26 trillion dollars not million not
billion we're talking trillion now
here's a question for you do you know
how much our trillion dollars is I mean
I'm sure you can do the math but do you
actually know what a trillion dollars
really means let me break it down to you
and a story if you and Jesus go into
business and you guys start a wine
business you're selling wine as an
example and you and Jesus are making 1
million dollars every single day buh
million boom million boom million every
single day and you added up two thousand
and 20 years later do you know how much
money you would have seven hundred and
thirty seven billion dollars you
wouldn't even have a trillion dollars
you and Jesus Christ so with that being
said we're gonna break down the 2.2
trillion dollar economic stimulus plan
known as the cares Act when I talk
trillions this is no joke
hope that story resonates with you now
with that being said now that we
understand what a trillion dollars
really is let's break down this 2.2
trillion dollar economic stimulus plan
so they care is act right what does it
stand for it's not just some cute Nathan
someone came up with hey we care no it
actually stands for something what does
it stand for you ask
well the coronavirus aid relief and
economic securities act that worked out
real nice now this was signed into law
March 27 2020 all right
we've all heard of the cares act we've
all seen it thrown around a little bit
but today we're gonna really understand
what it does for you as an individual
and for industries in America so it was
signed to protect the American people
and industries from the health and
economic impacts of kovat 19 so we're
all familiar with what happened in 2008
during the Great Recession well let me
tell you something this stimulus package
the cares Act was the largest economic
stimulus plan in modern history more
than doubling that of the 2008 Great
Recession these are massive massive
numbers here we covered what a trillion
dollars really means this is 2.2
trillion dollars now that it's
officially a recession 40 million jobs
have been lost unemployment rate is now
in the double digits here comes the
cares Act infusing money into the system
what we're gonna do right now is we're
going to break down the five major
components of the cares Act all right
component number one this went to
individuals and families this was a
total of six hundred and 3.7 billion
dollars that's made up 30% of the cares
Act let's break that down now of this
amount that went to individuals and
families 300 billion words in the form
of cash payments which you'll see here
in stimulus checks which will get which
will cover 260 billion of that went to
unemployment which we will cover as well
unemployment benefits and last but not
least 444 billion of that went to
student loan payments fYI if you did not
know this student loan payments are
suspended until September 30th of 2020
now
component number 2 went to big
businesses this is big corporate
bailouts now this is 500 billion dollars
which is 25% of the entirety of the
cares Act 425 billion of that was in
total of corporate loans but the bulk of
that went to the airline industry 58
billion went to the airline industry
number three was small business which is
a total of three hundred and seventy
seven billion which made up 19% of the
cares Act
this was administered by the SBA the
Small Business Administration they were
responsible for doling out loans new
loans made up three hundred and fifty
billion dollars of this 377 now
seventeen billion of it went to
lief of existing loans and only a puny
10 billion dollars is in the form of
grants now the difference between grants
and loans grants free money you don't
got to pay that back loans you got to
pay that back component number four went
to state and local government in the
amount of three hundred and forty
billion dollars that seventeen percent
of the entire amount to seventy four
billion of that went to covert response
sixty six billion of it went to schools
education child care and Family Services
and last component number five went to
public services that's a hundred and
eighty billion which is nine percent of
the entirety of the cares Act now the
majority of that a hundred billion
dollars went to hospitals and health
care providers to deal with the
coronavirus now the rest of that one's a
veteran stockpile equipment CDC food and
drugs to deal with the ramifications of
covin so now that we've covered these
five major components let's get more
into what this means for you and your
money this is all based on tax filings
of who received these stimulus checks
now if you're single and you're making
$75,000 a bless you more than likely
received a $1,200 stimulus check that's
the number for $75,000 or less and what
I'm gonna do is run you through a couple
different examples depending on what
you've made how much money you would
have received right so if you're single
seventy five thousand dollars or less
1200 bucks if you make $85,000 you're
receiving a stimulus check of seven
hundred bucks and last but not least if
you make ninety nine thousand dollars or
more zero money for you so that's how
that works now a head of household this
is the second component of the stimulus
checks you make a hundred and twelve
thousand dollars or less here's your
number twelve hundred bucks 125 grand
you get five hundred and seventy-five
bucks from the government from the IRS
last but not least here's the number you
make a hundred and forty six grand
another goose egg for you know money the
more you make the less money now last
but not least married couples married
couples if you're filing jointly you
make a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars or less you're getting twenty
four hundred bucks that's just 1200 1200
that equals twenty-four hundred that's
basic math for you right there
now you make a hundred and seventy five
grand that's one thousand one hundred
and fifty bucks in the form of a
stimulus check so last but not least you
making 198 grand as a family as a
married couple another goose egg for you
all right so a couple more pieces of
information you have children 16 or
under that's $500 per child so let's
just do some basic math here family of
four right family of four you receiving
$3,400 from the i-r-s that's how that
works here's a couple little pieces of
information for you you should
understand this this money is not
taxable stimulus checks not taxable
meaning you're not going to be paying
any taxes on a stimulus check now
another piece of information there's a
lot of scams out there a lot of scams
people want to take advantage of people
receiving money here's my piece of
advice for you the IRS will never
contact you via email they'll never
contact you via text they're never going
to hit you on social media it's only
through the mail so if anybody's
reaching out to you other than via the
mail from the IRS do not respond that's
probably a scam alright so for more
information on this here you go three
letters irs.gov go check out IRS gov
that's where you can find all
information regarding stimulus checks go
look into that now here's a little thing
that I've been doing some research of
where I've gotten all these numbers is I
have fun with this you might not have
fun you can check out the Forbes
stimulus calculator you can punch in how
much money you make you're married
you're single you're head of household
adjusted gross income you can kind of
play around it and see how we came up
with these numbers that's on the forbes
stimulus calculator all valuable
information right there now why were
these stimulus checks so important well
let me tell you something I don't know
if you know this but 78% of Americans
are living paycheck to paycheck that's
up from 75 percent only a year ago with
that being said in addition to the 300
billion dollars in the form of stimulus
checks now we're talking two hundred and
sixty billion dollars in the form of
unemployment benefits aka
unemployment insurance now here's the
difference between similar checks and
unemployment benefits stimulus checks
not taxable now what we're going to
cover right now under unemployment
taxable now I did some research one out
of three people don't even understand
that unemployment benefits are taxable
so now you know the more you know
traditionally if you're unemployed you
go through your State Department of
Labor your unemployment department
that's where you start now with Korona
going on there's a joint
state and federal program and let me
break down what this means to you at
home right so here we go so number one
if you are unemployed you start with
your state and what will happen is that
you most states will automatically
enroll you into the federal program so
now let's get into these numbers and
what this actually means for you at home
so most eligible Americans receive an
additional key word here an additional
$600 on top of what they would normally
receive from their state unemployment
insurance so the state national average
state national average per state is
three hundred and seventy eight dollars
so let's just break that down if the
state national average of what you'll
receive for unemployment is three
hundred and seventy eight dollars now
you're adding six hundred dollars on top
of that the average American is walking
away with 978 dollars a week that's over
fifty thousand dollars a year here's the
key part to stay home to be exact two
out of three out-of-work Americans are
earning more to stay home during kovat
than when they were actually working
does that blow your mind a little bit I
don't know how do you feel about that
how do you feel about that should people
be making more money to stay home than
when they were actually working
I'd love to get your input on that
please let me know in the comments below
but here's the catch here is the catch
right now
so this six hundred dollars a week of
unemployment as of now is supposed to
end on July 31st so that's that's coming
up that's coming up so July 31st is when
it's supposed to end again two out of
three out-of-work Americans are making
the equivalent of $50,000 a year to stay
home so a couple little facts for you
the states with the highest unemployment
let me break that down we got Hawaii
we got Michigan and we got Nevada states
with the lowest unemployment Connecticut
Minnesota and Nebraska the highest
weekly payment the state that pays the
highest weekly benefit Massachusetts
paying 823 dollars to an unemployed
individual state with the lowest
unemployment payment well that's
Mississippi why don't we if you live in
Mississippi
that's only 235 dollars that's a $600
weekly difference all right
speaking of $600 this $600 a week is
supposed to end July 31st as we've
discussed so what's next let's discover
what's going on next so Donald Trump
president Trump is signaling at more
stimulus checks he's basically saying
that they're going to be very generous
and big beautiful checks headed in your
direction he's saying quote unquote we
will be doing this so what will we be
doing we're about to find out well it's
no secret there was a three trillion
dollar Heroes Act that the House of
Representatives passed about a month ago
the Senate basically said it was DOA
dead on arrival
but that potentially will extend the
$600 a week of unemployment continue
1,200 checks and FYI this as we
discussed in the trillions will be the
largest stimulus package ever passed in
America if it happens so what I do know
that will happen is that in July we will
have answers why July because obviously
this ends July 31st and then there's a
two-week recess Congress has gone away
for the July 4th holiday starting July
3rd they're coming back July 17th and by
that point we're gonna probably have
some answers last piece of what's next
obviously they're the one thing we don't
know about is Kovan so with kovat cases
are on the rise states were closed down
businesses closed down they reopened
they reopen too soon now they're closing
back down again it's one big yo-yo going
up and down so we don't know what's
going to go on with that so the story
continues so now with all this being
said we've thrown together all these
numbers we see stimulus checks being
thrown around unemployment benefits
different colors different parts of the
economy how does this affect you point
number one short term versus long term
short term you might be collecting
unemployment money you might have
received a stimulus check long term
you're going to want to avoid being on
what I call the government program avoid
that as much as you can so the next time
something like this happens whether
that's in two years five years ten years
you're going to be off this list and
fending for yourself
point number two a budget a budget is a
game plan for your money and let me
break something down for you there's
something in the budgeting world called
the 50 30
what does that mean now what it
stipulates is 50% of your income should
go to your needs
30% should go to your wants and 20%
should go to your savings
now here's my advice for you right now
you should be prioritizing your needs
more than anything and your savings more
than anything cut out your wants this
isn't the time to be getting stuff that
you don't really really need cut out
your wants focus specifically on your
needs and on your saving point number
three paycheck mentality a paycheck
mentality as we discussed 78% of
Americans live paycheck to paycheck what
you're gonna want to do is graduate to a
net worth mentality so the next time
something like this happens you're not
relying on the government for your next
check graduate to a net worth mentality
point number four now's not the time to
be traveling now's not the time to be
partying now is not the time to be
balling out if you do if you are
collecting these checks what I would
recommend the best investment you can
make is actually the opposite paying off
debt if you have a high interest credit
card debt or high interest loans I would
take care of that immediately point
number five you're gonna hear me say
this all the time save that money you're
gonna need it I've been saying save that
money for years coronavirus hits and all
of a sudden people need to be saving
that money for most people you need to
save up $10,000 as a cushion god forbid
something like this happens again last
point is you need to invest specifically
invest in yourself you want to increase
your market value and recession-proof
your life so the next time something
like this happens you're again not on
this list so that's my take on the cares
Act and you know that once this heroes
Act is passed we will be covering that
right here on value tame and money now
if you want to know how money works
check out this video called the 20 rules
of money very informative and if you
have not please subscribe the value
tainment money we're going to be
covering stuff just like this on the
regular
and as always save that money
you